well let's cross now live to glasgow
where greta tunberg is about to address
that crowd of young people it is not a
secret that cop 26 is a failure
it should be obvious that we cannot
solve a crisis with the same methods
that got us into it in the first place
and more and more people are starting to
realize this
many are starting to ask themselves
what will it take for the people in
power to wake up
but let's be clear
they are already awake
they know exactly what they are doing
they know exactly what priceless values
they are sacrificing to maintain
business as usual
the leaders
are not doing nothing
they are actively creating loopholes and
shaping frameworks to benefit themselves
and to continue profiting from this
destructive system
this is an active choice by the leaders
to continue to let the exploitation of
people in nature and the destruction of
present and future living conditions to
take place
the cup has turned into a pr event
where leaders are giving beautiful
speeches and announcing fancy
commitments and targets
while behind the curtains the
governments of the global north
countries are still refusing to take any
drastic climate action
[Applause]
it seems like their main goal is to
continue to fight for the status quo
and cop 26 has been named the most
exclusionary cop ever
this is
with conference
this is now a global no queen wash
festival
[Applause]
a two-week long celebration of business
as usual and blah blah blah
[Applause]
the most affected people in the most
affected areas still remain unheard
and the voices of
future generations are drowning in their
green wash and empty words and promises
but the facts do not lie and we know
that our emperors are naked
to stay below the target set in the
paris agreements and thereby minimizing
the risk of setting off irreversible
chain reactions beyond human control we
need immediate drastic annual emission
cuts unlike anything the world has ever
seen and as we don't have the
technological solutions that alone will
do anything even close to that
that means we will have to fundamentally
change our society
and this is the uncomfortable result
of our leaders repeated failure to
address this crisis
at the current emissions rates
our remaining co2 budgets to give us the
best chances of staying below 1.5
degrees celsius will be gone within the
end of this decade
and the climate and ecological crisis of
course doesn't exist in a vacuum it is
directly tied to other crises and
injustices that date back to colonialism
and beyond crises based on the idea that
some people are worth more than others
and therefore have the right to steal
others to exploit others and to steal
their land and resources
and it is very naive of us to think that
we could solve this crisis without
addressing the root cause of it
but this is not going to be spoken about
inside the cup
it's just too uncomfortable it's much
easier for them to simply ignore the
historical depth that the countries of
the global north have towards the most
affected people and areas
and the question we must now ask
ourselves is
what is it that we are fighting for
are we fighting to save ourselves and
the living planet
or are we fighting to maintain business
as usual
our leaders say that we can have both
but the harsh truth is that that is not
possible in practice
the people in power can continue to live
in their bubble filled with their
fantasies like eternal growth on a
finite planet
and technological solutions
that will suddenly appear seemingly out
of nowhere and will erase all of these
crises just like that
all this while the while the world is
literally burned burning on fire and
while the people living on the front
lines are still
bearing the brunts of the climate crisis
they can continue to ignore the
consequences of their inaction
but history will judge them poorly and
we will not accept it
we don't need
any more distant
non-binding pledges
we don't need any more empty promises
we don't need any more commitments that
are full of loopholes and incomplete
statistics and that ignore the
historical emissions in climate justice
yet that is all that we are getting
and no that is not radical to say
just look at their track record
they have had 26 cops
they've had decades of blah blah blah
and where has that led us
over 50 percent of all our co2 emissions
have occurred since
1990 and about a third since 2005
all this while the media is reporting on
what people in power say that they are
going to do
rather than what they actually do
time and time again the media fails to
hold the people in power responsible for
their action and in action
as they
as they continue to expand fossil fuel
infrastructure opening up new coal mines
coal power plants granting new oil line
success and still refusing to do even
the bare minimum
like delivering delivering on the long
promised climate finance for loss and
damage to the most vulnerable and least
responsible countries this is shameful
[Applause]
some people say that we are being too
radical
but but the truth is that they are the
ones who are radical fighting to save
our life supporting systems
isn't radical at all
believing that our civilization as we
know it can survive a 2.7 degree or a 3
degree hotter world on the other hand is
not only
extremely radical it's pure madness
[Applause]
out here we speak the truth
the people in power are obviously scared
of the truth
yet no matter how hard they try
they cannot escape from it
they cannot ignore the scientific
consensus and above all they cannot
ignore us
the people
including their own children
they cannot ignore our screams as we
reclaim our power we are tired of their
blah blah blah
our leaders are not leading
this is what leadership looks like
[Applause]
thank you for showing up and see you
tomorrow again at the march